welcome to this video this is the drawn
seven yes round seven coverage of Tata
Steel 2014 and yeah this tournament
continues to be a real yeah real
celebration of fighting chest they
simply don't play any uneventful draws
that some that's fighting chess or no
BOTS but at least in terms of those
endless endless games like the 130 move
game from from yesterday we didn't have
any of those today but still lots of
interesting content all right let's
start with the first day i'm starting
with report against harikrishna and
again the Creator hungarian early on
comes up with a realm we have a coke on
classical with Bishop f5 this is the
classical variation and now report comes
up with the honey move Queen f3 I have
absolutely never seen this move before
and I did a video series for icc in
german language doing a black repertoire
and i did the coke on and also the
classical and I never ever looked at
this move yeah it's not it's not so bad
that's attacking the bishop black we
treated it yeah note that okay the clock
times RB backe I think I don't think I
krishna i had spent like 10 minutes on
nine minutes up to Bishop f5 yeah well
it's a it's a big surprise certainly
well probably how Krishna is not
surprised that report is coming up with
some sight line he's doing that
long in this tournament but of course
it's hard to guess what kind of sideline
and there is coming okay um yeah this
all looks very logical well 25 it's not
a move that it is that is strictly
necessary but it has some points I think
what black didn't want to do is to go
for something like this let's say 97
Bishop f4 90 f 6 and 96 I think this is
one thing that like probably wanted to
avoid however the fire just looking at
it now this is not necessarily bad wish
of a 3 yeah there's this this great move
well that's funny line checkmate oops
don't the Queen moves you've got this
check coming up very funny line okay now
I love just one brief idea after Bishop
f4 there's also this one yeah well
queena 3 is certainly not refuting the
classical choral calm but what I'm
trying to say is that this move was not
strictly necessary it's not bad though
we see that oh this is very logical and
all night f6 yeah this sir now leads to
some traits fatigues and black takes
with the pawn this is probably necessary
well not strictly necessary but after
this move up g 6 f g 6 this looks really
ugly and I'm not sure that like should
go for that especially considering that
there is this type of move
you can take on g2 and allow a g6 but
it's not nice and it's no problem to
capture with this pawn this looks a bit
like the Bronstein last variation now
with the double G F pawn takes yeah
white I didn't really have a big
alternative to that and now I played
Bishop b2 yeah at first sight this looks
totally harmless I mean I probably if I
would have this in the blitz games black
I would probably be very relaxed and say
okay well not much is going on but well
this cannot really be so great for what
yep probably it is not so great for
white but it has some interesting points
that are quite remarkable and we see em
that rather quickly there are some ideas
appearing for white Bishop d6 certainly
normal muth h5 we should move to c 2
yeah this is the first slide sign that
there are some things happening well
bishop age 7 there's just this morning
and this is one problem of the Flex
position this pawn is really a weakness
and at the moment the Rope is tied to it
you are theoretically speaking black
could have played h5 but this always
needs protection as well yeah obviously
it's not bad but it's it's interesting
that h6 is a real weakness room Bishop
c2 and now wipe late night f1 this kind
of retreating moves are often hard to
hard to miss on are easily dismissed if
you face them but this has some
interesting idea i wants to play 93 and
then c for opening up the position and
yeah we already saw that age 6 is a
weakness even
this type of maneuver can be an idea
intensifying the pressure on this point
black USB must be cautious here um yeah
here he also could have played the move
f5 this would have been interesting but
this is not so easy at all to play if
white plays b3 for example he's
threatening 93 and trapping this Bishop
so f form but then look H for this point
so hard to protect on f4 so we see that
there are some interesting points so
black must be must be cautious he played
a 6 which is probably just for control
of the b5 square this is a bit of a slow
move maybe this is already not so
accurate but he's committing a mistake
somewhat later so this is not the
decisive error or anything like that b3
atom dual purpose move he wants to block
this diagonal so robbing this bishop of
some squares and also wants to prepare
see form yeah and now black plate looks
e8 you know attacking c3 bishop d to
covering it and Rooker to g8 and I think
really that rope g8 is questionable it
looks very normal going to do on this
half open file and being active but I
think after that like has some trouble
my suggestion actually is to retreat it
all the way through to age 71 idea and
this is a bit of a wacky idea but that
is an idea to answer 93 without five and
then maybe a form with the temple
something like this should be okay for
black but it's a complicated and and
really am a fighting position that
probably would have led to two very
interesting claim he played rock jade
and this looks like a very normal move
but I think it lends black and some
troll 93 and now I'm here's the second
move that is probably not one hundred
percent precise I think we should be for
now wasps was maybe a bit bit trickier
the idea being if white kicks the bishop
that this b6 Bishop has an additional
square on g3 that it can enter with the
check with the temple and while f3 is
probably not the best move but maybe 94
was as mentioned at least a bit bit bit
chögyam after this white goes c4 and
this immediately leads to big trouble
for him this is just hanging you cannot
protect the pawn like this it's just
losing a piece and this means you
basically need to take it and after the
capture night takes it's a tempo on the
bishop note that this check would have
been possible if f3 had been provoked
before yeah not a knight c4 and
retreated all the way to f8 black it
also could have checked Bishop to c7 but
after move like Luke see one it did it's
a big threat IAM king is seven it does
not help the s Bishop b4 check or Bishop
a three and this really shows blacks
problem the b7 upon its it's just very
weak and something check like this is
looks looks like right out of a horror
musi for black terrible terrible night
checks
and and so on there should be seven
coming and it's just just really bad we
all event to evade with the with the
bishop Roxy one again threatening it's
remarkable how quickly now blacks
position goes downhill I think it's it's
almost beyond any salvation and it's
just an excellent game for white Bishop
by three and you cannot save it you
absolutely cannot save it if black plays
b5 for example the snide a5 and various
problems rook c 6 a-6 Bishop d7 to a six
yeah and this is just an excellent
square for white and blacks counter
players is basically nonexistent he has
no active play himself yeah this
basically means this is gone and he
played the night p 8 which does not look
brilliant but at XD for this is the idea
and now a report placed the strongest no
place tonight a five this is better than
taking on b7 after after this route d4
why does also better but Knight a5 is
even more powerful as here the night is
a real attacking piece and we see after
Bishop e3 group c seven bucks EA it was
also good my d7 that that right here y
term had a very strong move the plate he
played Knight a5 no but he had a very
strong alternative and this is Bishop to
c6 it seems that this move would have
one straight away it creates this very
very annoying pin and it's it's really
difficult to
to suggest move for black in fact this
has some amazing point and if black now
place the natural move King is a Blue
just for sure the first move you think
of too yeah maybe move the rock here and
get out of this pin I know this is also
a pin but here maybe you can move
through at least here White has a very
very strong move and if you want to
treat this as a puzzle trying to find
White's very strong move then I wish you
luck it sir not easy flip it and you can
pause the video I'll be silent for a
couple of seconds so that you can pause
it all right the strong move that white
ass is amazing look aged four yeah this
is just a hammer blow if black now takes
it it's a first mate roopa check check
King yet oopsies a check or forced King
evade check check King deuce book g7
looks like King is heaven check me and
rookie admit this is just a great made
look that look at the pieces they all
work together and the king is checkmated
very nice and in fact after Bishop c6
king is have luggage for if blanket does
not take it what movie supposed to play
the look is attacked and it's also
necessary to cover the seven so he has
no move if he moves like something like
that him this is this one
and yeah it has no square it's just
completely lost the compass on + 11 just
22 fifth to show how hopeless veces y a
bishop c6 was very strong he played
Knight a5 however and yeah it's a chain
the clock times are so inaccurate
probably he was a bit down hard time 95
and 96 or this still um keeps a decisive
advantage Bishop c6 only was check the
bit more forceful but this is also just
excellent for white if you look at the
position there are many things in whites
favor this is an offside bishop the pawn
is hanging there's potential two against
one with a with a passer to expect it to
be expected later and the main issue
those two pieces completely whoops and
you want to do that what is this those
are two pieces just hamper the King and
it cannot move and it's very close
always to a mating attack if one more
piece joint the tacit probably would be
a mate so this is still a lost position
hi Krishna goes for the the best defense
really the comp gives assess that by
heart toughest defense look g2g five
blocking the diagonal and therefore
avoiding the immediate capture on h6
closets it's an exchange and why takes
it now castle this is funny castles on
move 31 don't see that too often but
it's just strong you need to get the
rook involved and in order to not make
the video super long i'm going to show
the rest here relatively quickly report
does a decent job
technical wise is not allowing anything
special and always keeps his advantage
here here however could have won much
quicker with the help of b5 quite
surprising that he did do that because
after a b5 White has got the typical
with a 5 you're not recapturing and
giving our own but used the a porn and
supported by the night and the rook they
point is very close to promoting it's a
it's not clear how black should stop it
this is the easiest quickest win he
played 95 however attacking here and
attacking on f7 and this still win since
it's an exchange for no compensation can
go through the rest chat rather quickly
catch assets d April at the end is
decisive and the rooks are simply more
mobile than than the bishop the h6 pawn
also will be a weakness in the long run
check the zone still goes on for a while
and whites of course needs to be precise
but but he manages yeah as I mentioned
this is a weakness check
yeah we're down to rather basic and game
now and TM black resigned the apron will
just promote there's no counter play
whatsoever so harikrishna resigned very
i was very surprised how quickly out of
this very harmless looking position
black got into huge trouble and this
seemed the shows that a very normal
looking move that rock g aids can be a
big mistake it really seems that black
after that is in really substantial
trouble he could have with with bishop
before he could have put up some tougher
resistance but white will be better
after c4 there's no question about it
yeah so good win for report finally he's
scoring a good win again he had beaten
gelfand early on with the budapest um
and now his i think its second win he is
yeah he's having a hard time in this
tournament it's the first tournament
that is playing on with such a strong
opposition and opposition or in every
round I mean es played many is quite
quite a number of 2700 players before
but in this tournament he's getting
those players every time every round and
this is really tough so it's called a
good win and is closer again to the
fifty percent mark alright let's go to
the next game and this will be a kawana
against geary and I'm to be honest I'm
not entirely satisfied with what I am
analyzed for this game because I cannot
answer a very obvious question
wow I we'll see we'll see ok 5 and this
quite often means that gooey is going to
play the Petrov is playing the Petrov
quite often and we see that Kara wanna
is not interested 9 f 6 and here he goes
for the remarkable Knight c3 and this is
remarkable really am on the professional
level as this line is so yes simply not
giving white anything but nowadays
especially since magnus carlsen has
perfected this approach um them yeah the
the mission in the opening really has
been yeah the focus has shifted from try
to win quickly with prepared novelties
to just get a playable position and try
to outplay the opponent in in the middle
game in the end game whatever just play
a game this really has become more
popular this approach in gas opposed to
a very theoretical approach trying to
win games quickly with computer
preparation so those kind of sidelines
get get more popular um yeah the real
issue of this line is a night XD for
this is what curious playing um to be
honest I am myself i usually don't play
this move I play knight c6 yep getting a
bit more complicated play but 94 is some
is certainly a good move the the main
point is that night efore d5 is
instantly good for black and yeah you
get get the piece back with good play
something like that for example it's
very convenient for black and five is
not strictly necessary can also play
Bishop
60 96 and yeah this is this is directly
bad after d5 this gives black excellent
play with two bishops and the center
okay well this is very well known and
this is coming challenge what the heck
nope no challenge why is this happening
okay I only suppress chat but not
changes all right Queen age five this is
the real point of the opening attacking
f7 threatening made at the tech ed five
yeah like is going ninety-six covering
this and the teching see form this is
the main line and now Bishop to be three
yeah here black has a choice he can play
the game he can play um 96 this is the
the sharp the really sharp line or
Bishop to e7 and this is the solid one
here it goes for Bishop e7 diesel choice
knight c6 in fact can be answered by 95
and this is known as the I don't know
why it is called like that the front
Frankenstein Dracula variation right out
of a horror movie I really don't know
why you can maybe look it up on on the
internet why this is called Frankenstein
Dracula well no black player is going
for that and in a normal tournament game
because you never have it prepared and
it you cannot remember all the stuff so
we should be sent as a very sensible
choice Queenie 5 and castle so this is
just very solid ok d 496 well this whole
approach cannot be brilliant for white I
mean queen h 5v five moving the Queen
twice it shouldn't really need to an
edge
but in the meantime black has played a
night to d6 which is not brilliant as
long night a 5 an interesting move
trying to get the bishop but kawana
wants to keep this piece and he plays
Bishop to g5 and geary corrects the
night position going back to eight the
sugar 3 and 2 96 back he just wants to
complete his development yeah somewhere
around here thank Gary chooses some some
some inferior setup because white in
some moves really gets a nice position
we see that 92 9 s6 and 93 rupee 8 and
castles may be here is the point where
black needs to improve I think that 94
here was an interesting choice he should
try to harass wide screen because white
set up at the moment is not really her
moan yes the Queen on d to end the
nights on the farthest is not good at
the moment it has some potential to
really be a good setup but at the moment
it's not well coordinated maybe this was
the way to go he played a bishop f8 you
know I understand it I mean this was a
bit of in the way the bishop but look c4
g6 again 94 was interesting b3 just put
put those moves on the board and now why
it has an excellent control over d5 he's
got a good center and the pieces are
suddenly nicely placed white is
certainly better here it's not it's not
a very young it's not an advantage that
should lead to a dramatic quick attack
or made or whatever but white has
excellent advantage
the center and he keeps us this
advantage for a very long time 95 this
is a geological check 1995 black needs 3
328 I mean white had some alternatives
before this is this is clear very often
um it's a good idea to not exchange so
much he changed all the rooks maybe it
was an idea to keep them all but i don't
i don't really know I think white still
has a big edge but the thing is it's not
so easy to to give a direct
recommendation to white I think what you
should do and we play some some very
standard moves these kind of moves yeah
and now Giri takes on d5 you cannot
stand the side of this night any longer
and gives up the bishop hair this really
looks like a great position but the
thing is what i am i'm not able to do
and what I was basically inferring to at
the start of the video or at the side of
the game analysis I couldn't really find
a super convincing way from white
forward I mean this looks so fantastic
to bishops the center and this passive
bishop that right really am yeah I mean
white is close to having an almost
winning edge but how do you actually get
get ahead yeah it's not so easy what
what in general I think maybe koala
should have done but it's not very
convincing I know is maybe to play it a
bit slower like a 3 B 4
or bishops III and so on just tried to
gain more space and try to improve a bit
a bit more he played h5 perfectly
logical move 97 now okay want to keep
the bishop this is why it retreats and
now night f5 and black has this idea
night to have a bishop to have six
activated so white place d5 it's still a
great position queen of eight maybe
around here there's way to ways to
improve it's just fantastic position I
had a look at it with the computer and
it doesn't give a winning winning
continuation it gives a white steady big
edge but no direct win you cannot just
no attack on the King side and then meet
it also um I'm not sure plate the Bishop
g4 and queen age 6 21 and I g7 and black
somehow consolidates a bit now is
attacking h5 so white fur the client to
take it and here black yeah has some
defense of resources 98 and Bishop f6 is
the main one and here we go yeah black
has activated and we'll post the bishop
actively on the long diagonal I think
maybe this h4 h5 was mistimed around
here we see that a giri has improved his
position he's got some active play on
the long diagonal and after this III was
necessary to saying a5 also very logical
yeah it should be seven attacking the
night
we should be too was flight yeah this
move here it's why is the slope flavor
maybe something like this like this
attacking the line and as this looks a
bit risky they look at this may be here
oh this looks very risky yeah and it's
not necessary at all black plate Bishop
b2 and in fact here draw was agreed um
the problem is that yeah white will move
the bishop let's say here and after
something like Quincy three um it's
almost unavoidable to trade and with
this pawn being attacked something like
b5 is just completely equal position is
just too closed so koala certainly had
the big advantage but I couldn't really
find something concrete for what
probably should have advanced this pulse
a bit in a bit a bit slower fashion to
not allow this immediate regrouping but
it's a it's tough not not easy at all
okay let's go to the next game Gelfond
Aronian so we have girl font with the
bat tournament Aronian with an
outstanding performance is on more than
3,000 rating performance so let's see
what happens are only playing black yeah
the route goes in this is some an line
that aronian has played regularly in the
last couple of years it's been it was it
was more regular guest in his opening
repertoire like 23 years ago and you
didn't see that too often in the
recent recent tournaments but he is
going back to this this idea Bishop g5
yeah white has mean the main choice
between exchanging and playing this
bishop or play this Bishop immediately
one difference is after this Bishop with
the immediate bishop booth is that black
can play detects e4 leading to the
so-called Vienna variation after a fall
and now on the the overwhelming menu for
black a c5 recently and there also have
been many games with h6 interesting
alternative but c5 is the main move
leading to very sharply after e5 or
Bishop takes e4 however our own ian
plays b5 and this is the real surprise
as this move has a very dodgy reputation
normally it continues a for this is what
Galvan plate and SB 5 is hanging black
usually goes for c6 and this is a
transposition now to a sideline of the
bodhran excel is love when a black has
chosen a very questionable set up it
starts with e 5h 6ef oops I not rock a
fade route g8 and no I think h4 it's a
very long and sharp line that I
personally don't know too well but it's
it's good for white believe me this is
also why aronia didn't go for that she
had to hit some idea in mind after a
four I played the real funky move c5 up
attacking on one deform so it's c5 after
all but a four and b5 was inserted yeah
well what should why do he took on b5
not much else takes on d4 took on f6 and
took on d4 yeah we already see that
white is going to win upon c4 has pretty
much yeah impossible to key before black
and what does blacks compensation yeah
he's got let's put this on the board to
97 Quincy falling Bishop c5 this is
quite forced he's got the two bishops
this is nice and with the two bishops um
counts strong strong play or some play
on the dark squares as he's got the dark
squared bishop and this is missing in
white scam so the dark squares on a
somewhat weakened however is it enough
compensation to be honest I doubt it I'm
really surprised that Aronian went for
this line because it seems that why does
some white is better to be honest let's
put some more moves on the board this is
fairly logical Queen goes away from Lucy
farm and Bishop b6 this introduces this
idea amongst others I think right here
Gelfond um could have improved I think
you should try to keep more pieces on
the board maybe move like rook d1 um was
was in order there dear being too maybe
continue with night a for what he did is
he played the instant night a4 and this
after 95 seems to be okay for black the
point is that if I was hanging and it's
there's not much else besides what girl
for displaying check he took on the
eight takes and now he takes on c4
he could have taken on b6 but after a
be4 was attacked twice and you cannot
really save it besides this is not
really yeah a really valid extra point
or extra power well he took on c5 and
now here i think that black probably has
enough compensation he's got direct play
against be four and brought the bishop
now is really a strong piece he attacked
it and protected on the fourth rank but
black young he now has pretty easy play
hockey check just centralized pieces and
be okay the two bishops are strong yeah
girl font really tries to do something
and we see that a couple of moves later
here he is going for an interesting
exchange sack he could have also just
moved the rook yeah but well without any
big big progress being available he took
on a seven this is interesting giving up
the exchange and he's got the two pawns
in compensation and well then the rook
is a bit off side I think this is just
enough for the for the exchange I note
that the clock times are probably
completely bogus I'm really sure that
girl fun didn't didn't play so quickly
maybe I wrong yet it he sometimes does
that playing really quickly girlfriend
basically never does that okay well he's
got two pawns as mentioned and this is
probably enough compensation but it's
not more than that like it gets his rook
back into play
yeah there's not much going on the thing
is that this year is very solid for
white and black cannot really yeah he
cannot ignore the beep are basically
this always ties rook to to some passive
play and therefore here the games was
drawn yeah a bit of a strange opening
choice from aronian but risky it seems
um but rather quickly he didn't have any
problems maybe night a4 really was a bit
a bit too early looks like rookie one
here looks looks more testing so
slightly dodgy game baroni and i think
but he managed to draw it okay so next
game Wesley so against coyoacán we have
a Queen's Indian not a big surprise
Caillou kindness playing this opening
for ages Chase Utley since is playing
chess I believe yeah this is one of the
main lines and this position can also
easily arise from the from the Catalan
opening yeah a fraud this is an
interesting plan for white wood why does
am trying to do is to make some sense
out of this D to Bishop this d to Bishop
has been tricked yeah the bishop has
been tricked to d2 with this check on
before right here and usually this piece
is better on v2 I think I already
explained that in in a recent video that
this check is a good tool for black to
this place this piece yandi to yeah so
what white is trying to do with a force
to make some sense out of this
and advanced with a 485 which wouldn't
be possible without the bishop k h6 so
black is basically saying okay I can
play some strengthening moves you don't
really have a threat 983 yeah I guess
after a five there is no way of Fred I
can play any move basically against that
or any program with Quincy a droopy ate
something like that yeah I first played
93 and I'll see five black ass goin from
an opening of the center Queen B 2 and B
from interesting try to open up the
queenside guy took on c4 and took on
before this sum is yeah a simple
solution to this position black also had
other options but let's get ahead this
is an interesting way to play he allowed
96 which at first looks very nice for
white but black has some idea with this
he is giving up the dark squares
especially d6 for increased control over
the light squares he's got very good
light square control and we see after a
five and Bishop before that there are
the first concrete threats now took and
Roxy to this initiate a very interesting
sequence Queen B 5 gotta trade and now
after e3 this was hanging at all black
gap plays a look-see 8 and this is a
very interesting decision because it
involves them a sacrifice after nighty
one taking the rook yeah okay
theoretically speaking you don't need to
sacrifice now
well could also just retrieve the rook
but Kai Atkins idea with rook c8 was was
different he took on g2 this is very
interesting after 92 he just recaptured
here and entered this position being
whole exchange down but he's got some
compensation of course he's got the
second-ranked f2 was the target and of
course 94 is eyeing exactly this target
with the temple this Bishop is attacked
yeah it needs to move it and now a very
interesting decision the black could
have taken on f2 and this is probably
the move that almost all amateur players
would play in this position while
decides the fact that they probably
wouldn't willingly sect the exchange but
this is so obvious that you take it with
check that almost all players would
would go for that but kayaking has
looked into this position much deeper he
played b5 and this is a strong move the
ideas that d 7 is the worst piece if you
look at this before b5 this night is not
going anywhere it can go to have six but
you don't want to allow the silly bishop
to trade here to treat himself against
the night why is it a silly bishop yeah
because it does not take anything it's
just moving yeah internet at the moment
it's not it's not a very aggressive
piece and beehive is introducing this
idea he wants to activate his worst this
is his worst piece and this is working
very nicely in the game we'll get one
not covering f2 we cannot let it hang
all the time 96 yeah white tries to
exchange like declines that and with
King g1 widest try to to still play for
when they could have played Roxy one
to draw and go from actual but he wants
to fight King g1 and now 95 winning a
temple bishop moves at Knight c3 yeah
and black has very active night cm those
two pieces are just ajust a real
annoyance black also has the idea to use
the beep on note that the knight on d5
is covering the before square so that he
really is supporting the pond and the
knight on c3 of course is covering the
all-important promotion square so the
pawn is dangerous and the two nights are
simply very strong white has a hard time
to ever expel those pieces he cannot
play me for this is controlled if he
plays f3 there's III hanging so let's
say something like that not too great
yeah this position is not easy at all
for white to play because of like the
activity I don't think black is better
don't I don't want to convey this this
impression but black has some
substantial compensation played rook a
seven and now h5 gaining some space this
is a potential idea and we see that
after b7 is playing g5 if black manages
to play g4 then it will be very very
difficult for white to ever get rid of
the Knights as the light squares are
totally blockaded he decided to to take
drastic measures here quite surprising I
think the next movie played g4 and the
ideas after the capture to play Bishop
to b6 and now this Bishop can help with
securing the king it's a really
surprising decision but probably
playable we see that in the game
black obtains very strong pulse for his
nice but it's also becoming a parent
rather quickly that black is not able to
to strengthen his position any anymore
after Knight c3 and turn this capture
him he took the chance to just liquidate
into a drone ending adhere we had four
against four on one on one week I didn't
really check I don't think they did they
play it on for for much longer no no now
here it was drawn yes simply no way
forward for both sides an interesting
exchange psychic by Pelican if white had
chances to feud it it must have been
rather early I think early in the
sequence I mean around here after black
gotti I think he has really enough
compensation for the exchange the
computer and does not really am a proof
this agree with this judgment that this
is maybe enough compensation
compensation it always gives white more
than one point wattage but I don't see
it I don't see how to how to make much
progress iam white probably could have
played better and set more problems but
it's not easy at all to play this
position ok let's go to the next game
night edge against doom English or doing
guess yeah NIDA jism currently at the
bottom of the of the standing so having
the real bad tournament and well
sometimes the mindset of a player can
can be can be read with the first couple
of moves and here we go
knowledge is going for the London system
a notoriously boring opening but well
this is an opening that really says okay
this tournament is not going to well
let's just play am a simple kind of
position not going for any any big sharp
tactics right out of the opening this is
quite remarkable for for nitrogen
because he's a really really sharp
player and a fighter so we probably is
really not too thrilled with his
performance so far yeah domingus is some
playing one of the good setups against
the london in fact this is one set up
that i had recommended in in a small
video series that i did I don't know
about what are the half years ago for my
for my channel why I where I am
demonstrated some good ways to fight the
London system and this is one of the
systems that like and play it's um a
very flexible set up with a double via
cheto both bishops have nice positions
and black now according to circumstances
can consider to play e5 or see 5 or
sometimes be five after some corporation
it's very flexible and why term does not
really have a very obvious active play
here this bishop for example is biting
on this phone I don't want to focus too
much on on the opening even just
advanced a couple of moves the plane
mostly divorce around the Queen side
yeah this is a funny move
96 leading to the Sun change of
structure around here white looks looks
quite okay I mean you should not be in
any trouble but somewhat later we'll see
that around here that black attacking
the rook provokes white whites response
b3 and after this strats position here
on this exchange exchanges the correct
word we have come to a position where a
black has got the a pond as a passport
and whites compensation lies in this
slightly big pawn on d6 and the passive
bishop here well White's bishop is
attacking this pawn I think white really
should should be okay here shouldn't be
in trouble but this is quite typical
form for a game where one player has
some is really in bad shape in a
tournament did you tend to drift into
trouble even out of positions where you
don't really expect to have big trouble
I think black black is easier to play
because black just pushes the apron
every Scott the chance and what needs to
generate some play against that if we
continue a couple of moves yeah and try
to put more pressure on the porn
yeah this looks like a nice tactic but
it does not lead to much yeah rugby 7
this in fact is a real mistake the
problem is that after simple move d5
cutting this white yeah probably must
trade and now the apron is really
dangerous we see that it's coming up
quickly a 3 & a 2 & yeah white needs to
play the somewhat passive looking move
okay one and rather quickly now black
gap is making progress yeah and here
with this threat coming up we will see
that white needs to right here ya know
like once goes for for the bishop c3
move what has this funny tech the group
takes a two because of black Sam wicking
check again this is a checkmate
checkmate to avoid therefore black needs
to take with the Queen and now Quinn
Texas result we have come to a position
where black is some up an exchange but
white has quite strong bishop on e5 and
he's got some ideas for counter play is
this position a win for black maybe
maybe I'm not one hundred percent sure
maybe like eighty to ninety percent that
black should win but it's not so easy we
see that
after a couple of moves here that it's
not so easy to see how black should
should continue here I think right here
his um maybe not playing the best one
but all this is is not so so easy to
analyze especially considering if you if
you have limited time and this is a
position type where the computer just
plainly sucks it to put it very very
clearly because the computer does not
understand fortresses and white can
sometimes set up a fortress however what
I what I do believe is that black should
try okay one hand with the idea night a
62 f 1 and this I think is very
difficult to defend one important point
is that Queen f6 here after takes and
now probably Bishop takes us the
toughest one that this is probably
losing at first I thought this might be
drawable but I don't think it is black
can go all the way to f5 and get get to
a zoosk one I will put it on the board
just to show that the general idea yeah
might of course cannot do much he needs
to prevent king e four so we get to this
position and here I had some initial
problems to see how black should should
continue but he has a good continuation
and this is much more apparent for the
human than for the computer surprisingly
route 87 is the is the key move the
problem being that after something like
that
I need to lose 10 personal how do you do
that maybe like that what I damn it I
did it I did this wrong ready of course
here I need to do this this is the
position that that black must go for
this is the zooks one the bishop has no
square to go to without leaving this
poor not protected so white must play a
king move and this is exactly the point
where you can advance with your king if
white plays f3 he exposes the second
rank and if he does not then black wall
will enter here and this is in fact to
win this is just one one method that i
wanted to show how to to make progress
in this position in the game dominguez
played queen f5 and i'm not sure that
this is winning I mean it should of
course better for black but is it a wet
check heart attack we gave a couple
checks and then move the rock that was
under attack yeah Queen a free and yeah
yeah he decided to trade and yeah I'm
absolutely unsure but I think I think
white should draw to be honest in the
game let's let's look at this f6 okay
cannot take cheap oh this should be six
what is trying to exchange pawns check
yeah this is very logical all of that
but the problem is out of this here
black is a whole exchange up but I still
think it's a dead wrong if you feed this
to the computer it gives black
completely winning edge like plus to
point something but if you then analyzed
for a while you recognize that this is
just just bogus because it cannot make
any progress in the game we see that
like after some shuffling chatterjee for
check and even played h3 check and there
is no progress to be made white just
move this Bishop eternally and draws the
computer is still on plus two something
I mean Houdini honor on a good good quad
quad core and if you give it to stock
fish which is of course some good
weekend is on minus four which is
completely ridiculous in fact in the
game after a couple of more moves here
they agreed to raw it's just a draw and
the computer is helpless because it does
not recognize that it is an exchange
that's all great but you don't you don't
make any progress simply it's a nice but
not winning okay so just one game left
and already above the one-hour mark I
really thought this would be so wrong
but I have no I really cannot make a
short video it's not possible okay
Nakamura against van really I camera
playing eform now he's more of a default
player recently but also a form part of
his repertoire and then various one of
the guys who really almost always placed
some
going for the sharp fight and is playing
this this set up that interestingly
enough does not have a name this type of
Sicilian it very often transpose to the
scaling and variation for example if
white plays a move like you should be
too like just plays Knight f6 and
transposes to the scale ravening and to
try to pronounce it correctly it's not
entirely correct but I'm close um very
often it transposase but there are some
independent points of course like I'm
going on now is playing the sharpest
move and this is G form it's very very
similar to the cameras attack but of
course there's no knight on f6 to attack
if black now place Knight f6 which it's
not entirely logical but if he would do
that then g5 transposed to the Keres
attack off the slave vonnegan however
fan really played night g to e 7 this is
an interesting twist he just avoids the
kick that the knight on f6 is son this
is receiving and he tries to use this
night first only seven and then maybe on
the queenside or on the Kings side just
according to circumstances this is some
I think nowadays the main move here
night be three this makes some sense if
white plays on a slow move let's say
this one for example then black I think
we'll trade one pair of knights and
activators e7 night so this tries to
keep the snide a bit passive for the
moment okay but black has other moves on
the queenside
yeah this is all fairly logical and now
I think that really is playing a really
good setup first rook c8 we need to and
now is playing age 5 and this is a good
move i think it just stops White's play
on the on the Kings side and the capture
here is only a leading to travel for
white after black recaptures black will
be the one to play on the G file and
this is not the pneumonias position for
white and ok white therefore cannot take
and this means that after a form we can
put this on the world and now g6
Blackwell fianchetto would have a really
secure king after short castles and this
is very important after Bishop f4 Bishop
g7 rugby one attacking here black gown
was basically forced to play 95 and
Knight takes before so white has a as 1
upon but after night see for taking here
93 night Queen B 6 castles and castles I
wanted to to get to this position of
course before this was not a sequence of
false moves but I wanted to get to this
position to them to talk about this
position type it's a position where
black is Pawn down he has he needed to
yeah to give up the B porn but what is
this compensation and he has
compensation he's got an excellent night
on c4 that applies pressure here
combined with the bishop he's got a safe
king this is very good what the heck
he's got a safe king this is very
important with this setup his king is
really secure also the bishop of course
provide some shelter he's got more
targets like that and on the other hand
it's not so apparent what what white is
doing in this position the main asset
that white has is this porn apart from
that he does not have a very clear plan
him and long term he has some one issue
and this is the king right now the king
is completely okay because there are
pieces around it but in the further
course of the game this King can be a
problem in the long run Black's king
will always be safer with this pawn
chatter and yeah I think that this is
fairly equal in this position well not
equal like draw ish not at all but
dynamically equal yeah the cameras next
move is very logical he played this one
in lie to d2 he's fighting against
blacks best piece this man makes lots of
sense and yeah black has no way to avoid
the trade he played rook to the eighth
covering the important d 6 x and y took
ya hear he had a choice he could play
the game move which is really
spectacular I could have played in a
more restrained fashion the most obvious
move here is b3 sorry I was boiling it
this is what he played be three years
that is the normal move and this sum was
the the solid alternative yeah probably
black would play rook to
23 and still the sea to Paula says the
target here an additional idea that
black hands in this position is knight
c6 to not down sorry knight c6 to d4
this is a really good square so this was
some an interesting alternative for
white but I guess he was too tempted by
95 it's very understandable 95s the move
that you really want to play once you
but once you have spotted it yeah it's
it's an attack now this this look is
attacked but what happens after the
capture yeah this is also hanging the
point is Bishop e3 gaining this tempo on
the Queen and we see that the screen is
simply overloaded it cannot protect both
looks and this means that black only has
got one reply and only move and this is
rook see to deform looking quite funny
to get into this pin especially
considering that white has c3 and the
real the real remarkable thing is that
this window of an exchange still needs
to a position where black has quite
decent compensation it's a full exchange
but it's not so clear to be honest um he
played Bishop to c6 attacking this week
porn and I believe that the next move is
may be questionable and I don't
understand it this is my main problem I
don't understand I cameras next move I
understand that the suggestion that I'm
going to make is a bit
but I still believe that it is better
than what he played my suggestion is to
to play Quincy to not this move play
Queen c2 to just cover a form the thing
is i mean this rook is you can always
capture it you don't need to capture it
right away and after quincy to for
example just just one line on not quite
i'm not quite sure what black should do
but just to show the general the general
point if like moose wherever yeah you
will take and in this type of position
Black has some compensation he's got the
good porn here with e 5 96 he goes to
important squares this is still weak he
has some compensation but I don't think
it's more than more than enough I mean
it's interesting that fan really I'm got
into this this type of position maybe it
happened yeah by accident sometimes it
does you you underestimate or misjudge a
move like 95 and then you you suddenly
get to get into into this position um
but I really think my camera should play
here and then then take it he played b 3
i'm going for a sequence of moves that
basically sacrifices the whole Queen
side and I don't really get it I mean
maybe I'm overlooking something after
Queen c2 and while the engine also
overlooking a of course I checked it
with the computer and the computer gives
black um enough compensation and this
position and basically assesses this all
this as equal which is quite quite
remarkable for
decision and exchange down but it does
not find anything spectacular for for
black so it's not clear why not come
were avoided that especially considering
lo and look at what happened in the game
he played b3 queen bee three now it took
the exchange yeah Black has just 12
points here he's got two points now for
the exchange and only a couple of moves
later we see that round here here Black
is excellently coordinated he's got
those two pawns supported by the strong
bishop on b5 and he has many ways to
improve this position knight c6 24 and
so on also note that this is of course a
very very strong piece to be honest in a
practical game I think widest almost
lost him blacks players just so much
easier he's got the strong passer and
white has no real real play a couple of
moves later we see that right here my
camera plays rugby to see one here he
could have played a bit tougher defense
by by the only have waiting moves let's
say King King g2 and then it it
continues um the problem of his movies
just is just e 2 and here there's no
move this is attacked and where do you
go would be one is not really helping
and this is falling with a deadly attack
yeah so you you basically need to take
on d 2 takes and Bishop b5 ya hear the
the big point is that after a beam
and Bishop b2 yeah rook takes c6 check
it's not helping at all this is just a
great diagonal Bishop b2 now that's 94
this is the big point it threatens 92
check and it threatens Queen takes d2
and Queen takes the 2 is even working
after this mission is protected let's
say Creed III for example like just
takes it and Jesus this uses this fork
note that quite some time ago I
mentioned that Lex king is much safer
this is still valid and now with some
pieces exchanged the White King is
really feeling yeah the yeah the lack of
protection check played rook c8 check
king age 7 and 27 yes I like just check
check uses his night to attack the king
and that the end captures only form yeah
now he threatens Queen g4 check with the
maid to come so the Queen needed to
retreat check and it's still just an
excellent attack check yeah King edge
from checkmate direct mid so this was
necessary check check yeah you can you
can torture but check well now you need
to play another goof and you just took
the night at the bishop sorry just took
the bishop and after takes and taking on
g5 white is completely lost twin g-form
this just too much he tried to Queen f4
oh this is quite funny if black now
takes
check this is a draw okay i didn't i
didn't even look at the last couple of
moves i didn't know that this stale made
joke was I wasn't there okay but he just
took it on the eighth the the rook check
and after this check my camera resigned
so the world number three lost a game
here against been really a very very
complicated game and the main mystery at
least for me is why Nakamura played this
right here why he played be three this
is just mysterious at least my chest
understanding is it's not it's not
enough he I don't understand why not why
not Quincy too I mean I really don't
know I mean this is not the reason it
can just take here and why this better I
don't know why I gave up on both pawns
on the queenside and after that it was
just very one-sided affair with black
having much the easier game it's much
easier to be be black in this position
all right I really no video almost 80
minutes I hope you're not not to sleep
yet okay thanks for watching tomorrow
and it's again rest day for the
tournament I think I don't know I think
I believe they against which location
for one round to Amsterdam so there's an
additional rest day this means that i'll
be back tomorrow on a bit not tomorrow
on on Tuesday the 21st with the 888
round right yeah round eight alright
thanks for watching and I'll be back as
mentioned on Tuesday